Earth's ideal conditions for life
stem from its optimal position in the cosmos,
offering liquid water and Protection from meteorites.
The magnetic field
shaped by molten material in the core
Shields against space particles
as revealed by ancient rocks through paleomagnetism.
Fluctuations in the field's intensity
influenced by the outer cores turbulent flow
lead to unpredictable polarity reversals.
During low intensity phases,
earth faces increased exposure to solar
wind and cosmic rays impacting the atmosphere.
While no direct link to mass extinctions is certain,
uncertainties persist,
imposing risks to human civilization
during periods of reduced geomagnetic intensity.
The sporadic nature of these changes
emphasizes the need for preparedness.